في بلدة صغيرة تسمى نيويورك في
شرق أوكرانيا ، وعلى بعد رحلة قصيرة
لقنبلة هاون من منطقة المتمردين ،
يقع شارع سلافيانسكا
بعد ثماني سنوات من الحرب ، لذا فإن
المنازل القريبة من الخطوط الأمامية هنا تكاد تكون
عديمة القيمة
لم تحطمها الحرب.
لقد دمرها الصراع على الفقر وتم
هدمه وبيعه حيث
يخبرنا السكان المحليون من الطوب والبلاط المعاد تدويره أن هذه
المنازل تبيع بحوالي 70 دولارًا ،
هذه نهاية شارع سلوفانسكا الآن
أسفل نقطة التفتيش وما
وراءها يسيطر عليها المتمردون  المنطقة
وفي الساعة الماضية أو نحو ذلك ، سمعنا
ما لا يقل عن ثمانية انفجارات
زنبق ، ثلاث انفجارات
كانت خارجًا وسط القصف وأمها
مدت يدها وهي
تلعب مع جرو العائلة عبر بوابة
مليئة بفتحات الشظايا من
قذيفة سقطت قبل أن تنطلق.  ولدت
والداها ليخبراها أن آخر
وابل من
القصف كان
رعدًا ، لكن هذا أمر يدعو للقلق بشأن عدم وجود أي شيء.  السلطات العينية
كان هناك ما لا يقل عن 70 غارة على طول خط المواجهة يوم
السبت ،
لذا ما نوع الحياة
التي تعتقد أن ابنتك ستعيشها
بالأمس
، يُنظر إلى قصف المتمردين المتزايد المدعوم من
روسيا والذي أسفر عن مقتل جنديين حكوميين
يوم السبت على أنه
مقدمة محتملة  إلى غزو روسي ،
ربما على طول هذا الشارع بالذات على
الجانب الآخر من الطريق ، يسحب مقولة المياه من
بئر يعود هذا المجتمع إلى
القرن التاسع عشر
والخوف يثقل كاهل الجميع ،
هل هناك الكثير من القصف ، أليس
لديك هذا منذ فترة طويلة ،
هل تشعر  خائفون الآن
ولكن العديد ممن يعيشون في نيويورك في أوكرانيا
محاصرون بسبب موسيقى البلوز في زمن الحرب
سام كيلي سي إن نيويورك أوكرانيا